Every punch you've thrown, every kick you've landed
they have all led you here to this
moment to the ultimate fight.
Who am I fighting? a being who stands against all there ever was or will be the apocalypse
itself the anti-monitor it's time to
get your friends we defeat the
anti-monitor and find a way to get all
the people we lost back.
All life ends. Only I am eternal!
we'll see about that if we're gonna go
down we go down fighting
Let's do this!
is this what all the crossovers are like
not exactly
every punch you thrown every arrow you
fire they have all led you here to this
moment. Oliver? There's no way out of here. I have to try again.
Barry, the effort alone could kill you. out of my way put it out we're not turning on each other
Try and Stop me!
I wish you could see this the birthplace of all creation.
You have to get out of there. Get out of there right now!
what the hell just happened? where are we?  this is the vanishing point
what does that mean it's a point outside
of time and space
what happened to the Waverider and the
others the anti-monitor he used
Harbinger to attack us pariah must have
sent us here knowing that the
anti-monitor couldn't follow well you
have to go back we have to go back right now!
Barry we can't they're gone
Something's wrong! Kal? Kal!
Something's wrong!
Please, fix it. Fix it.
What do we do?
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have a brand new crisis on Infinite
Earths trailer for part 4 and part 5
it's really like a two-part finale that
they're airing back-to-back so we'll
break it down if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the easter-egg videos there's a bunch of
stuff that they have to close down and
set up for the next seasons for all the
shows don't forget they're actually
doing a Green Lantern series on HBO max
in the next couple of years I think it's
going to be 2021 premiere but it's made by
the same people that are making the
arrowverse shows so I'll talk about some
Green Lantern stuff during this video
too but they also kind of have to set up
the Superman TV show I think they're
filming the pilot for that later this
spring but they also just renewed all
the air / shows so arrow is obviously
going off the air that's ending in the
next couple of episodes but all the
other shows are coming back for next
season the trailer itself just picks up
with the Jim Corrigan version of The
Spectre teaching Oliver about his new
powers and his mission as the new
Spectre of the arrowverse it's not
totally clear why he has to pass the
mantle of The Spectre onto Oliver but
this is Oliver wearing his costume as
the Spectre so he has that long green
robe that he wears instead of the
traditional arrow costume I'm a little
disappointed that there aren't some more
special effects involved with his
character like he looks pretty regular
as the Spectre when in fact the Spectre
is one of the most powerful characters
in the DC Universe he also frequently
exists in this really giant state just
looking down at anyone that he's talking
to I don't know if they're going to do that
at all during the episodes but they're
still in this real version of purgatory
Lian Yu not just the metaphorical
purgatory the real purgatory Lian Yu is
also the real-world Chinese word for
purgatory but when they did Leanne you
on the arrow pilot and made it a
foundation for the show they were using
it as purgatory in a more metaphorical
sense like it was the metaphor for
Oliver dying and then being reborn as
the hood character obviously that was
before he became the arrow and then the
green arrow they have the big montage of
him fighting the main villains from each
season Malcolm Merlyn Deathstroke
Rachael cool Damian dark Prometheus
Ricardo Diaz aka Richard dragon
everything that you've done has led you
to this moment so the sort of saying that he's been
training this whole time to become the
Justice of the real arrow multiverse
because that is what's happening
the specter is the literal embodiment of
God's wrath he is God's justice so he is
now justice in a literal sense for the
entire multiverse but this rock quarry
place where they're fighting the
anti-monitor and shadow demon minions is supposed to be the dawn of the
multiverse like the very first world
within the multiverse the origin of time
itself you get a little preview for that
through the monitors character in the
ante monitors backstory in the other
part of the trailer I wish you could see
this like you see him talking to that
woman this seems like a much younger
version of the monitor without his
trademark beard working on a machine
that sends him back to the dawn of time
just because he's a curious scientist
and wants to see it that's actually a
bit of a change to the monitor in the
ante monitors back story in the comics
I'll explain that in a second but in the
last episode that we saw he said that he
had a family once but they were killed
like Heep remembers them fondly so I'm
guessing that this was the wife that he
had before she died you see what seems
like the younger version of the monitor
seeing the anti-monitor at the dawn of
time so it's not totally clear how they
changed the ante monitors origin story
from the comics because in the last
fight when the anti-monitor finally
kills the monitor and absorbs the rest
of his power he calls him Mobius so it
sounds like they're giving him some of
the newer backstory from Justice League
dark side war mobius became the
anti-monitor of the DC Universe when he
found the anti-life equation and it
forever altered him to become the
anti-monitor that you see here but the
anti-monitor just started out as a
normal scientist that got too curious
for his own good curiosity killed the
cat or turned him into the anti-monitor
he's the one that created the Mobius
chair that you always see the new God
Metron flying around and he created the
chair to take him back to the origin of
the anti-life equation and try to learn
what it all meant what it seems that
they're doing for the monitor's
backstory is giving him some of the
anti-monitor origin story from the
original crisis on Infinite Earths right
after the new 52 when they did Justice
League dark side war Geoff Johns changed
the origin story of the anti-monitor a
little bit he was just a normal
scientist who wanted to see the dawn of
the universe he wanted to see the Big
Bang so he created a machine to take him
there but when he arrived and saw this
giant cosmic hand reaching out of the
Big Bang explosion he was cursed to
become the anti-monitor for witnessing
something that he wasn't supposed to see
the easter-egg about the cosmic hand that he
saw reaching out of the Big Bang is that
it's a big origin story for the Green
Lantern comics the hand belonged to the
owen scientist Crona remember the Owens
are the ones that created the Green
Lantern Corps so he himself had also
tried to witness the Big Bang in his
attempt caused this accident that you
see fracturing the single universe
during the Big Bang into infinite pieces
creating the DC multiverse there might
be some Easter eggs for that during the
episodes they kind of yadda yadda yadda
their way through a lot of this
backstory like how come we only got a
couple hours to do this story so we're
just going to give me the CliffsNotes
version for all these characters they
finally bring the reverse-flash back
like there was the line in Nora's future
newspaper reverse-flash scene leading
army of shadow demons but we've seen the
last couple of episodes that the
anti-monitor has either been forcing
other people to help him or tricking
them in the case of the pariah character
there are a whole bunch of scenes with
them later in the trailer though on a
version of earth that looks like has
been brought back so they're almost
literally doing the plot of Avengers
endgame and Avengers infinity war
everybody gets snapped they get their
asses handed to them by the ANSI monitor
then they find a way to quote-unquote
snap a bunch of people back and have
their big final battle in related news
the big stuff that's happening right now
is they're filming the Batman movie with
Robert Pattinson we've actually gotten a
look at him on this set but we haven't
seen what his official Batman costume is
going to look like that'll probably
happen pretty soon the first big Batman
trailer will probably drop either at
Comic Con or they might wait to the end
of the year in November early December
but we will get a Batman trailer before
the end of the year they're also filming
the Black Adam movie really soon while
the trailer for that before the end of
the year and they said that they're
filming Shazam - really soon - but
that's not coming out till 2022 so it's
probably going to be a long time before I
see any footage for that there's a whole
bunch of other DC stuff happening
they'll be more Wonder Woman 1984
trailers coming really soon so if you
have any big requests for Easter egg
videos or questions you want me to do
videos for just let me know in the
comments uh that just is trashcan
It's just a trashcan. Yeah, yeah.
congratulations Babak daya you're the
giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details
everyone click here for that really big
Doctor Strange 2 announcement that
Marvel just made in everyone click here
for my last big Wonder Woman 1984 Trailer
thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight!